For average person, computer is some sort
of machine which allows them to use certain
applications.
At the same time, mathematically, you can
define a computer as a concrete mathematical
model and study its properties.
You can study which computational problems
can be solved fast, which problems cannot
be solved fast.
This is done using quite deep mathematical
techniques.
I grew up in this town called Ichalkaranji
in India.
In both my and my wife's family, everybody's
a doctor, except for me and my wife.
And in fact, in the natural course of humans,
I would have ended up being a doctor.
But there was some lucky coincidences.
I ended up being a mathematician.
It's a bit difficult for me to say what I
do when I'm not doing math, because that's
what I'm doing most of the time.
But I enjoy a lot playing with my son Neev.
For me, work and enjoyment or work and relaxing,
these are all really the same.
It might come as a surprise to you that we
are so interested in knowing that certain
computational problems cannot be solved and
in particular cannot be solved fast.
We ought to investigate both the power as
well as limitations of our methods.
From practical point of view, it's often useful
that certain computational tasks cannot be performed.
For example, I'm sure you would be happy to
know that a hacker cannot break into your
bank account and steal all your money.
One of the important contributions has been
proposing the Unique Games Conjecture and
then developing research around this conjecture.
I was vacationing in India, visiting family.
This small idea came to me that if I used
this Unique Games conjecture as a starting
point of my field of research, it would really
make the whole field easier and very consistent.
I will describe the kind of games that I like
to play by giving an example.
So this is really a puzzle constructed by
my collaborator Dana Moshkovitz.
On the left-hand side you have categories
such as animals, verbs, transportations and
so on.
And on the right-hand side you have a column
of boxes, and you want to fill up these boxes
with letters.
So you have to pick out words for different
categories on the left-hand side so they are
consistent with the letters that you put on
the right-hand side.
So it's a puzzle.
Puzzles of this kind, if they are very large
in size, computers cannot solve these puzzles
fast or efficiently.
So that's really the P not equals NP conjecture.
If the conjecture is true, then would be really
nice.
It's as if all the pieces of a big puzzle,
they are kind of fitting together very nicely.
I knew that Assaf Naor nominated me for the
prize this year.
It wasn't clear to me what a huge honor this
was until I actually received a call from
the president of the International Math Union.
Receiving the prize does place additional
responsibility on the recipient, but maybe
all these additional responsibilities are
for the better.